cdc director dr richelle wilinski joins
us now good morning to you dr wilinski
it's good to see you
good morning gail thanks for having me
so here we go the biden administration
is calling june the month of action you
know june is normally weddings
graduations father's day but now month
of action they're saying
people get your vaccine and we just
heard in ouija's piece
all the incentives that are being
offered anything from donuts which by
the way i did claim
uh guns alcohol sports tickets
free day care do you think all what do
you think of all these incentives number
one and number two do you think
they're working you know
um june is going to be the month of
weddings in the month of vaccination
so i'm really excited for the month of
campaigning for vaccination
ahead and you know i think we need to
understand that
people may have not gotten vaccinated to
date
for various reasons it may not have been
easy it may not have been convenient
they may
not have had the incentive that they
wanted or needed um or they may have
questions about the science and
and the um and and how quickly we cut
we were able to get three safe and
effective vaccines
so really what this month is going to be
about is meeting people where they are
understanding what they need in order to
get vaccinated the information that they
need the resources that they need the
access that they need
well they're certainly making it they're
making it easy and certainly giving
access we keep hearing that we need to
reach
70 percent why is the 70 percent number
so effective
so important rather important you know
we want to get the majority of america
vaccinated and after we get to 70
my goal is going to be to get to 80
percent i think what we really
understand
is that this virus is an opportunist and
it will go to places where people are
not vaccinated
and so um you are safe if you are
vaccinated you are not safe if you are
not vaccinated
and my job is to keep america safe so we
will work to get to 70
on june 4th and then we will continue to
work to get beyond that
i like the part where you're saying
you're safe if you are vaccinated
because
just so you know all of us sitting at
the table are vaccinated a lot of people
are starting to go back to work and some
of your co-workers will not be
vaccinated
how concerned should we be i got in a
cab the other day
the driver wasn't vaccinated made me
very nervous go to a movie theater
you're sitting with people they're not
vaccinated how should we handle this how
worried should we be
i know that it's not safe for them as it
is for us but what about us who are
vaccinated
being around those people so for those
of us who are vaccinated we have seen
in study after study now not just the
clinical trials but in the real world
settings that these vaccines are
protecting
more than 90 to 95 percent of people
from getting
any disease at all they're even better
at protecting against severe disease and
hospitalization
so for the most part nothing's a hundred
percent full proof but for the most part
if you are vaccinated
and you don't have an immunosuppressing
disease for example
you really are safe from
potential disease around you we've also
seen that these vaccines are working
against
are the variants that are circulating
here and that's a really important
component as well
should companies require their employees
who are coming back to work be
vaccinated
you know i think that that's going to
have to be at the individual company
level
um certainly there may be some places
where companies feel like that would be
the best way to go that people would be
safer that people would
feel safer coming back into the
workplace so that we're going to leave
at the
the company level and i'm i'm almost
embarrassed to ask you this but on tick
tock there's a video going around right
now have you seen it
and somebody did it to me you put the
coin on your arm
if it stays there it means that you're
that there's a chip in your arm
it's a big thing that's going on tick
tock right now
can you just put that to rest and say
how ridiculous it is
that that we are not being injected with
chips
is what i want we are not being injected
with chips what we're being injected
with is this
incredible scientific breakthrough that
keeps us safe
and um is effective against something
that has
has killed hundreds of thousands of
americans over the last 15 months
what concerns you now as we sit here
today this this third day of june
i know you want us to get vaccinated but
other than that what are you worried
about
um i am worried about what's happening
around the world
i'm worried about uh variants if we have
continued circulating virus
i'm worried that there will be people
who don't believe that this vaccine will
protect them and that we are relying on
every each and every individual to step
up
all right dr wolinski we thank you we
saw you throwing out the ball
the other day on a scale of one to ten
what would you give yourself
i'm going for like an eight
okay fair enough thank you so much for
your time
thank you bye